you know project my name is Chris K I'm
from the city called Bandler Tennessee
which is about 50 miles west of
Nashville my project is entitled
electromagnetic levitation a digital
control system basically constructing an
analog device or the series of analog
devices leading up to this digital
system that's capable of holding well
what the what is now a balsa wood
airplane and it can hold just about
anything that you can fit underneath it
this fits a certain weight class which
is about 5 ounces so I probably haven't
ridden up too much firmware for it the
firmware is run on an ethanol mega 1:28
microcontroller and it's written in C an
AVR studio compiled and then sent from
the actual chip interface wizard that I
used in debugging the system basically
right now what it's doing is controlling
each channel independently and there's
two Hall effect sensors one above and
one below each electromagnet and then
what basically what it does is it
samples the difference between the two
sensors which gives the relative the
magnetic flux that the actual magnet on
the object is exerting on the system and
then that information is converted to
digital basically digital registers
inside the chip and then the chip is
using Hardware PWM to output the signals
that it needs to control the strengths
of the magnets and I get a feedback
system set up that is inverse to
distance and that's what you see
apparently my screwdriver and my plane
and it hold up just about anything else
feel like putting under there provided
that you trim again so just about any
kind of magnetic object or even a
ferromagnetic object that doesn't
inherently have any magnetic properties
like what you see there can be suspended